It is the best-selling book in history.
No volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted. And its words,
sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious, should always be studied
carefully. It is the Bible, the word of
God. Welcome to Bible Answers Live,
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. To receive any of the Bible
resources mentioned in this broadcast,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, here's your host from Amazing Facts
International, Pastor Doug Batchelor.
Hello, friends. How are you doing? Would
you like to hear an amazing fact?
In our world, death is a universal fact
of life, unless you're a jellyfish.
This has been revealed in a new study by
researchers at the University of Oviedo
in Spain.
The jellyfish, Turritopsis Dohrnii, is
the only known species that appears to
be able to rejuvenate repeatedly after
reproduction, becoming biologically
immortal.
Scientists are hoping its DNA might hold
the answer to the secret of eternal
life.
Most creatures age because their DNA
degrades over time, but the T. Dohrnii
pulls off an amazing biological feat to
cheat death.
Every member of the species is an
identical clone, and it starts life as a
polyp that then matures to an organism
called a medusa.
This isn't particularly unique, but
what's amazing about the T. Dohrnii is
that if the medusas get injured, sick,
or old, they become a cyst that turns
back into a polyp and restarts the whole
process, churning out more clones.
Scientists call it life cycle reversal.
It'd be something like if a person got
old and turned back into a fetus, or a
chicken turned back into an egg.
Christian scientists have often
wondered, how can we have eternal bodies
in heaven,
like this immortal jellyfish seems to
have been giving us some valuable
insights on how DNA can repair itself.
And I think this is fascinating, Pastor
Ross. They've always wondered,
you know, doesn't everything grow old?
And how do we have eternal glorified
bodies?
Bodies that are doing real things.
Well, this gives us a little insight
that uh there's at least one creature
down here that seems to have DNA that
doesn't degrade. It's rather remarkable
when you think about it. So, this this
um octopus gets old, or jellyfish gets
old,
and uh then it figures, well, my life's
coming to an end, so I'm going to grow
this little nodule, and from that
eventually develops into another octopus
and has the same DNA. So, it's not
exactly the same octopus that, you know,
lives on or jellyfish. It's not the
exact same one, but
nevertheless, it's it's coming from that
that jellyfish. So, it just continues.
It's
rather interesting. So, yeah, I was
researching a little bit today on what
causes aging, and the scientists have
sort of agreed
there is no one silver bullet. Aging
seems to happen because a lot of things
start to happen at the same time. So,
even if you found a solution for the
DNA, there's other things, and it's like
a perfect storm as you get older.
And uh
I suppose whatever God had in that tree
of life
would have the enzymes or whatever it is
that we're missing now. But we'll have
that in heaven. DNA won't grow old, and
and we won't grow old. You know, there's
that promise in Revelation 21:4,
and God will wipe away every tear from
their eyes, and there'll be no more
death, nor sorrow, nor crying. Neither
shall there be any more pain, for the
former things have passed away.
A world with no more death.
You know, sometimes people hear about
heaven, and they think, wow, this place
where you live forever and everything's
perfect. Could it really be real? Well,
the Bible says it's real. It's the home
of the redeemed. And we have a book.
It's called Heaven, Is It for Real? And
this is the free offer. We're happy to
send it to anyone who would call and
ask. The number to call is 800-835-6747.
And you can ask for the study guide.
It's actually one of our books, not just
a study guide. It's an actual book. It's
called Heaven, Is It for Real? We'll be
happy to send it out to anyone who calls
and asks. Now, we do have listeners that
are outside of North America, and if
you'd like to read the book, we
encourage you to go to the website, just
amazingfacts.org.
You'll be able to read it there on our
library at the website. Amen.
Well, Pastor Doug, we have a number of
callers who are lined up. So, um before
we get to it though, let's start with a
word of prayer. Dear Father, once again,
we thank you for the opportunity to be
able to open your word and study.
Indeed, Lord, your word is a lamp to our
feet and a light to our path, and
for us to come to a knowledge of the
truth is life. So, we do ask your
blessing upon our time. Be with those
who are listening, wherever they might
be.
In Jesus' name. Amen. Amen.
Well, we've got a number of callers who
are lined up here, and so we're going to
go to our first caller of this evening.
We've got Martha listening in
California.
Martha, welcome to the program.
Hi. Thank you, pastors. Um
my my question tonight, it's only come
up a couple times, but it was always in
a professional situation, and wasn't
an appropriate discussion for the time.
But I've had the comment made to me more
than once that Jonathan and David were
homosexual lovers. Now, I know they
loved each other a lot, but
you know, the way God spoke of them, I
know that's not true. I just want to
know how to handle it scripturally.
Yeah, I would actually say that they the
um
the question really begs the evidence.
What would lead a person to say that?
They're assuming because it says that
David loved Jonathan. And actually says
that when Jonathan died, David says, I
loved you more than the love of a man
for a woman.
Well, that that is not homosexuality.
That's saying it's different. He and
clearly, Jonathan was married and had
children. He had a son named
Mephibosheth. David had at least 10
wives.
Uh and I think it's just kind of part of
our sick society. They're assuming that
if a man loves a friend, it must be
sexual. But there's nothing in the text
to hint that the love of David and
Jonathan was anything other than a
profound love of two friends that were
of one heart.
Um yeah.
So, it's it's hard to persuade people
that have their minds made up to read
something into it that's not in there.
Mhm. Absolutely. All right. Well, thank
you, Martha. We've got um Britney
listening also from California. Britney,
welcome to the program.
Hey.
Hi.
And your question.
Well, my question is, who is the
Antichrist?
Ooh, big question.
Well, in a nutshell, the in the word
Antichrist, you know, it means against.
The Antichrist is something or power
that is against Christ.
Um
historically,
the Protestant Church felt like the
church that had developed in Rome
fulfilled that definition of the mother
of harlots. You know, a church is
compared to a bride.
And um
they had believed the Protestant
reformers like Luther and Calvin and
everyone from Spurgeon to Wesley, they
saw what happened with the church
becoming a political power in Rome
that it had become Antichrist in its
teachings. That didn't mean that all the
Roman Catholics were lost.
It meant that its organization, its
structure began to teach things that
were contrary to Christ. You know,
things uh for one thing, they got
involved in idolatry. I think everyone
can see that. It's one of the
commandments. And the the regal way that
the priests and the popes were treated
when Jesus was, you know,
he he didn't have a place to lie his
head,
and they're the representatives or the
vicars of Christ.
Typically, the the Protestants
identified the the papacy as the
Antichrist. More specifically, the
office of the pope. And the Antichrist,
as you said, is one who is opposed to
Christ, but it also has
uh an added definition, and that is to
put oneself in the place of Christ.
of Christ. Receiving worship or homage.
And of course, we know that from the
medieval church that crept into
Christianity. Now, we have a lesson. We
do. It's called Who Is the Antichrist?
And we'll be happy to send it to you, uh
Britney, or anyone who calls and asks.
The number to call is 800-835-6747.
And you can ask for the study guide.
It's called Who Is the Antichrist? And
we'll send that to you. It's part of the
Amazing Facts study guides. It's a whole
series of lessons that get into a number
of very important topics in the Bible.
And we encourage you, if not gone
through those lessons, uh you need to do
so. Just also ask when you call, say,
I'd like to enroll in the free Amazing
Facts Bible course. And they'll be happy
to do that.
We've got Anthony listening in New York.
Anthony, welcome to the program.
Hello, good evening, pastors. Um
Evening. My question
um
has to it has to do with two verses, uh
Matthew chapter 24:29,
I think we lost you. You there, Pastor
Anthony? You there?
Sorry. Uh yes, Matthew chapter 24:29,
and Revelation 6:13 and 14. And I want
to know how to reconcile the two because
I've always learned that um you know,
they said
some of uh the the moon turning to blood
and the sun darkening and the stars
falling has already happened in the
past. I've heard that in, you know,
Revelation's seminars. They say these
things have happened already. But then
in Matthew chapter 24:29, it appears to
say that it's going to happen after the
great tribulation.
Um so I'm just trying to figure out how
to reconcile those two. No, that's a
good That's a good legitimate question.
Uh there are some of the prophecies that
Jesus gives, especially in Matthew 24,
where you've actually got the the
prophecies repeat themselves. You might
call that a dual application.
An example will be
the disciples are asking three questions
in Matthew 24. They say, "When will
these things be?" He had just said
Jerusalem would be destroyed. There
would not be left one stone upon another
at the temple. So they're asking about
the destruction of Jerusalem. Then they
said, "And what is the sign of your
coming?" So they're asking about signs
in the end of the world.
So he gives them signs through history.
He talks about the destruction of
Jerusalem, and he gives them more
specific things about his return and the
end of the world.
So um
the things that happen with the sun
turning dark and the moon turning to
blood and the stars falling from heaven,
there have been historically some and
great earthquake, there have
historically been some great uh cases of
these things that happened after the
time periods given in the prophecy.
But they will happen again in quick
succession
at the return of Christ.
So
uh I guess the easy answer is to say
they happen more than once. That's what
you would call a dual application of
prophecy.
Yes, there's also two tribulations
that's spoken of uh both Matthew 24 and
also in Revelation. You have the 1260
years of um people supremacy from 538
until 1798. That was a time of trouble.
That was a tribulation for
Bible-believing Christians. Many of them
were persecuted. You had the Protestant
Reformation.
Uh that's one time of trouble, but then
you have another time of trouble
according to Daniel chapter 10 uh Daniel
chapter
Where is it? 12:1, where Michael stands
up and there is a great time of trouble
worse than the world has ever seen. That
hasn't yet happened. That's in the
future. So there are two times of
trouble. So immediately after the
tribulation of those days
there were three times of trouble. I
think that Oh, you mean Jerusalem as
well? Yeah, there's Yeah, he's also
talking about the fall of Jerusalem. So
that that would be one.
Yeah.
And then of course Jesus said
immediately after the tribulation of
those days, then there'll be, you know,
a great earthquake, the sun will turn
dark, and so on. And we have the Lisbon
earthquake in 1755 all the way up to the
falling of the stars in 1833. So we have
succession of the dark day and the blood
moon. And the the concentrated places of
Christianity on the planet saw these
things. And so they they they even took
them as signs in the day they were
happening.
All right. Well, thank you for your
call.
question. We've got E. Frank listening
from New York. E. Frank, welcome to the
program.
Yes, uh good evening, uh Pastor Doug.
Good evening. And Pastor Ross. Uh I have
a question that's been pondering me
my person for many, many years now. It's
in regards to the Quaker faith. Mhm. Um
I uh have a um a story that has to do
with a girl that was in my
second grade class. She would always
be attached to me and offer me
membership in the Friends
Meeting Quaker Society. And I asked her
at that time if uh
Quakers believe in in holy scripture.
And she said, "No, not We don't believe
in scripture. We believe that God works
within us. And that God works through
every single human being on Earth. We
don't believe in discriminating against
anyone.
And we we cer- certainly we apply the
teachings of Jesus most of the time
to our beliefs. Uh and I am very
confused because they do say that they
believe in Christ. They believe in the
Bible, but they profess to
uh have a belief in humanism, in other
words. So could
Could you rectify that, Pastor Doug?
Well, I'll do my best. Of course, the
Quaker religion, as with a number of
denominations, you know, the Lutherans
today are different from the Lutherans
in the days of Martin Luther.
Methodists today,
Calvinists are different than they were
in the days of John Wesley or John
Calvin.
The Quakers today, their beliefs you
know, originally they were trying to
base their beliefs off the Bible,
but over time they began to put more and
more emphasis on the inner feeling and
the spirit. So pretty soon they got
where the the feelings and the spirit be
in the experience began to trump
scripture.
And it it was more important.
Um I remember growing up eating a lot of
Quaker oatmeal with the you know, the
picture of the Puritan-looking Quaker
with the hat and so forth. But they
they've changed quite a bit over the
years, and it's more like a society now
because
um if you want to argue with them from
scripture, you probably won't get very
far. They use some scripture, they you
know, they believe in loving their
brothers and they're they're uh
nonviolent um when it comes to war.
But um
on a number of other doctrinal areas,
it's uh pretty diverges pretty far from
scripture.
So hope that helps a little, E. Frank.
Thank you for your question. Next caller
that we have is Derek listening in
Minnesota. Derek, welcome to the
program.
Hello, hi Pastor Doug. Hi Pastor Ross.
Hi. I have a Hi, I have a quick
question.
I brought this up in my Sabbath school,
and the elder gave me a really weird
book. Like it was blasphemous, but I
thought you I've heard you mention sort
of that Jesus had Joseph's DNA somehow.
And I'm not really sure how you
explained it, but I I mentioned it, and
they looked at me like I was crazy. So
I'm not really sure what you think.
Well, let me be clear. And I think when
I did make that statement, I've I've
tried to also be clear that, you know,
we don't have a DNA sample of Jesus to
measure with a DNA sample of Joseph to
give you a an answer on that.
The Bible says that Christ was conceived
of the Holy Spirit.
And I I've talked to Jewish scholars
before that said that uh these are
Jewish Christians.
They said that it's entirely possible
for God to inseminate Mary
you with the Holy Spirit and something
divine and still have attributes of
Joseph. It's certainly not hard for the
Lord.
And one of their arguments for that is
that um
the gene- genealogy of Jesus, the one
given in Matthew, follows the line of
Joseph
to David.
And if there's no blood relation to
Joseph, why does it happen? Well,
you know, that's one argument. And then
of course the genealogy uh in Luke, I
think it's tracing through
uh Joseph's father-in-law, which would
be Mary's father.
So you know, we don't know, but it it's
entirely possible that um
God took something of Joseph also
um
and had that in
in um Mary.
Uh it certainly was a
a miraculous event. I but I would not
die on that mountain. It was just a
theory.
All right. Well, thank you, Derek. And
of course, Pastor Doug, just to clarify,
you you you're fully agreed that um
you know, Christ was miraculously Mary
was a virgin when she gave birth to to
Jesus.
yeah, yeah. Yeah, there's no question
about that.
of by the Holy Spirit, I was just saying
that wh- whatever that sperm is that God
used to inseminate Mary, it would not
have been beyond the Lord to have some
attributes of Joseph. I don't know, you
know. Right. So yeah. Okay.
That if that happens, that solves the
problem of why are there two
genealogies. Right. Right.
All right. Thank you. Julie's listening
in South Dakota. Julie, welcome to the
program.
Well, well, thank you very much,
pastors.
Um I was wondering, I believe that Jesus
is going to return very soon. And so
what can a person do to make sure
they're saved before he returns?
Well, first of all, I wouldn't let the
return of Christ be the only motive.
Uh I think every one of us is blessed to
have another day of life and another
breath or heartbeat. And so we want to
know
immediately
say, "Lord, is my life in your hands?"
And to follow the simple criteria that
God gives to come humbly, sincerely,
confess that we are sinners, confess our
sins to God, repent of our sins,
and say you accept the sacrifice
of Jesus on the cross and his shed blood
in your behalf that you might be
forgiven and given a new birth, a new
heart, and a new life.
And um
I'd say you might need to do that more
than once. In other words, Paul said, "I
die daily."
Means he died to himself every day,
experienced a new birth each day,
and um
just keep your relationship with the
Lord fresh and growing.
And and we've got a book on three steps
to heaven.
That's right. That's what I was thinking
about. It's a great resource kind of
help encourage anyone how you can have
that daily connection with Christ. It's
called Three Steps to Heaven. We'll be
happy to send the book to anyone who
calls and asks. The number again is
800-835-6747.
Just ask for the book. It's called Three
Steps to Heaven. We'll be happy to send
it to anyone who calls and asks.
We've got uh Gina listening in
California. Uh Gina, welcome to the
program.
Thank you so much. Hello, pastors. Uh
please, my question is about uh being
meek, meekness from the Bible, because
that does not mean weak. And we're
called to be soldiers for Christ. And so
please, could you give a better
definition or some examples?
Yeah. You know, well, for one thing, the
Bible talks about Moses as being one of
the meekest mans in all the Earth. Mo-
Moses was very strong leader in the way
that he boldly went before Pharaoh and
said, "Let my people go." Jesus was
incredibly strong and courageous and
brave,
but he was also very humble
in that he would not claim his rights.
He, you know, took children up in his
arms. He was The Bible says he was
gentle and lowly.
Now, people will confuse meekness with
weakness, and they really are completely
different things.
You can have a very brave, courageous,
strong man who's also meek
and humble.
And uh so, there one is, you know, an
attitude of humility. It's not a a trait
of weakness.
All right. Well, thank you, Gina. Next
caller is uh Perlita listening in New
York. Perlita, welcome to the program.
Yes, uh sir.
Uh I want to ask to our pastor about uh
Matthew 24:30.
It said here,
"At that time, the sign of the Son of
Man will appear in the sky, and all the
nations of the earth will mourn. They
will see the Son of Man coming on the
clouds of the sky with uh power and
great glory." Is this the rapture of the
church, pastor?
Well, when they see the Lord coming,
uh this is a visible uh coming of the
Lord. This is connected with 1
Thessalonians 4,
where it says that
"The Lord himself will descend from
heaven with a shout, with the voice of
the archangel, the trump of God. The
dead in Christ will rise. Then we who
are alive and remain will be caught up
together with them in the clouds.
So shall we ever be with the Lord." So,
when we are caught up,
uh after our bodies are transformed,
that is a rapture. It's just not a
secret, because you got a trumpet, the
glory of the Lord coming with the
angels. So, we would respectfully
disagree with those who say that the the
people are going to disappear secretly.
We think it's a very visible rapture
that takes place. That's what the word
rapture means, to be caught up.
So, the Bible teaches that when Jesus
comes, uh life's not going to continue
on earth normally. Uh the dead are going
to be destroyed with the brightness of
his coming. The righteous are going to
be caught up into the air with Jesus.
So, yes, nothing secret about the second
coming of Christ. People will take the
verse where it says, "But he's coming as
a thief." And they think that means
secretly, but they've got to read that
whole verse
in 2 Peter chapter 3, and I think it
starts with verse 8. It says, "The day
of the Lord will come as a thief in the
night, in which the heavens pass away
with a great noise, and the elements
melt with fervent heat, and the earth
and the things in it are burned up." So,
as Pastor Ross said, when the Lord comes
as a thief, life doesn't go on for 7
more years.
You know, got a book talking about this
called Anything But Secret. And again,
we'll send this to anyone who calls and
asks. The number is 800-835-6747.
You can ask for the book. It's called
Anything But Secret. It's all about the
second coming of Christ and the rapture
of the saints when we're caught up to
meet Jesus in the air and what happens
to the wicked. Thank you for your call.
Next caller that we have is um
we got uh Mobi listening in Canada.
Mobi, welcome.
Mobi in Canada, yes, you're on the air.
Good evening.
Evening.
And your question?
Yes, I have a question
um regarding, you know, I mean, um first
year students I'm doing computer science
in this um course.
Um we're in I mean, like in the academic
role.
Um you know, it's just
I'm just frustrated with, you know,
teaching of evolution and
and I I just doubt, you know, creation
and, you know, what the purpose of human
life is.
I've been really um doubting it. Yeah.
Can you, you know, show me verses to,
you know, help me to encourage my faith?
Yeah, well, as far as verses, there's no
question if you believe the Bible, it
tells us that God created the world in
six literal days. You'll find that in
Genesis 1 and 2.
Um and several times through the Bible,
uh Jesus reiterates that God created
everything. Uh John says that God made
all things through Christ. And so, the
divine creation is from cover to cover,
even in, you know, Revelation 14,
"Worship him that made
the heaven and the earth and the sea and
the fountains of water." So, there's
lots of scripture, but I used to be an
evolutionist. And the more I thought
about it, the more I realized that
evolution is extremely illogical.
And for me, the most powerful argument
is that you have no example anywhere in
the observable universe
where you get inner working systems and
complicated, organized design, and all
these symbiotic relationships,
uh and just complicated,
incredibly
exquisite design
by chance.
You know, a human body and the way that
our eyes and our ears and our brains
work is so sophisticated. The idea that
that happened
by accident through,
you know, biological processes, and that
we have no purpose. We're all just these
biological algae on the planet,
that is so hard to
to comprehend.
For example,
if you're walking through the desert
and you see a motorcycle up on a
kickstand out in the middle of the
desert,
and you know something about
motorcycles, and you hop on, you kick
it, and it starts, and you ride off.
Would you ever ever believe that that
motorcycle came up out of the sand?
No, it came from a motorcycle factory
where engineers worked a long time on
developing that motorcycle, and a very
uh an international process of
assembling the parts and materials to
make that motorcycle. You know, I accept
that. It's extremely complicated.
We are much more complicated than a car
or a motorcycle.
And to think that these inner working
systems happened by accident to me is
uh it's
a powerful proof that there has to be an
intelligent God
for the complexity of life we have on
our planet. You know, we got a book.
It's called How Evolution Flunked the
Science Test. And it talks about these
these uh dilemmas that, well, science
can't explain. And we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks.
The number is 800-835-6747.
And ask for the book How Evolution
Flunked the Science Test, and we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks.
Well, Pastor Doug, I'm looking at the
clock. We don't have enough time to take
another caller before we have our break.
So, friends, we still have another half
an hour or so of Bible questions, and we
see a number of folks who are all lined
up with your Bible questions. So, going
to take a quick break and give some
important announcements, and then we'll
be back with more Bible questions.
Absolutely. And in the meantime, don't
forget to just write down
amazingfacts.org
so you can check things out through the
week. We'll be back more questions in
just a moment.
Stay tuned. Bible Answers Live will
return shortly.
In 6 days, God created the heavens and
the earth.
For thousands of years, man has
worshipped God on the seventh day of the
week. Now, each week, millions of people
worship on the first day.
What happened? Why did God create a day
of rest? Does it really matter what day
we worship? Who is behind this great
shift? Discover the truth behind God's
law and how it was changed. Visit
sabbathtruth.com.
Jerusalem, the city of peace, has been a
place of unending conflict for
centuries. Many now believe that
Jerusalem will soon take center stage
again. But what does the Bible say? The
fall and rise of Jerusalem presents the
vital history you need to know about
Jerusalem and its role in end-time Bible
prophecy. This Amazing Facts edition of
the classic volume The Great Controversy
is the perfect sharing book. Get your
copy at afbookstore.com.
Would you like to know God's plan for
our troubled world and solutions for
your life's challenges? Beautifully
redesigned and updated, Amazing Facts 27
Bible Study Guides provide
straightforward, Bible-based answers
that are enlightening, encouraging, and
easy to understand, giving you real,
relevant Bible answers to questions
like, "How can I have healthier
relationships? When will Jesus come?"
and much more. Order yours today by
visiting afbookstore.com
or by calling 800-538-7275.
You're listening to Bible Answers Live,
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you. So, what are you waiting for?
Get practical answers about the good
book for a better life today.
This broadcast is a previously recorded
episode. If you'd like answers to your
Bible-related questions on the air,
please call us next Sunday between 7:00
p.m. and 8:00 p.m. Pacific Time. To
receive any of the Bible resources
mentioned in this evening's program,
call 800-835-6747.
Once again, that's 800-835-6747.
Now, let's rejoin our hosts for more
Bible Answers Live.
Welcome back, listening friends, to
Bible Answers Live. And for any of you
who tuned in along the way, this is a
live, international, interactive Bible
study.
And we're just so thankful that you're
joining us. Uh my name is Doug
Batchelor. My name is Jean Ross, and we
have Anastasia who is listening in
Canada. Anastasia, welcome to to
program.
Hey, hello. Hi.
Hi. Um I just had a question about I
think it's Proverbs 13 when it talks
about don't spare the rod and spoil the
child. Mhm.
So um to me I think that's like a
metaphor for a discipline, but like I
like I know some people might think that
literally means like if your kids are
doing bad things like hit them.
Like I've heard people say that before
and I'm not too sure
cuz I'm pretty sure like Jesus doesn't
hit us when we do things wrong.
So I just wanted to know your take on
that.
Yeah, well the Lord is of course a
loving God, but I think the Bible does
teach that God disciplines us.
And it doesn't mean that he smacks us
down with a rod every time we do
something wrong. There's a a broad
spectrum of ways that you might
discipline
uh your child. It might be quiet time.
It might be taking away some privilege.
But the Bible also says that the Lord
chastens every son who he loves. I think
it's in Hebrews as well as in Proverbs.
And uh
sometimes that might mean doing
something where you inflict appropriate
uh pain.
It might be on the posterior. Now I've
got six kids
and you know sometimes because I love
them
and I don't want them to die
uh when they kept meandering off into
the street as after I say do not go in
the street, do not go in the street and
they wouldn't listen
um
out of love for them I might give them a
little bit of pain
uh so that you know you spank them. I
know there I said the word.
That um
they might go who?
That hurts. I don't want to do that
again. It the fact is
that
everybody remembers.
Um the way we learn is through pain.
And the reason I don't keep grabbing
things off the stove without a potholder
is cuz I've done it with without a
potholder and that just you only have to
do it once or twice.
And then you learn.
It's interesting
real quick.
A couple weeks ago I was cutting wood in
the hills and I tossed a piece of wood
on a yellow jacket nest.
And they came swarming out like a bit
twice.
I will never drive by that spot again.
Even though they'll be gone soon. I'll
never drive by that spot again and
forget that experience.
I'll always know.
And so there's something about pain
helps us survive. And so sometimes you
might paddle a child if uh Yeah,
especially if the child is young. Now
you know, obviously when they're old
enough to make decisions and you know
Like 21 you start stopping.
to try some creative things. When they
get a little older.
But when a child is young sometimes you
need to kind of slap them on the hand
and say that's hot, don't touch it
because uh you don't want them to hurt
themselves. So the verse you're
referring to you've got of course
Proverbs 3:12, but then also Hebrews
chapter 12 verse 6 it says for whom the
Lord loves he chasteneth and scourges
every son whom he receives. So
uh there we have the idea of God does
bring discipline to to guide us and lead
us.
All right, thank you Anastasia. We've
got Terrence listening from uh North
Carolina. Terrence, welcome to the
program.
Hey, thanks for taking my call. I got a
question for you as in
reference to according to our rewarded
according to our works in uh
Romans 2:6 that there's dozens of
verses for this and um I guess it would
be with um
you know a little humorous for Pastor
Doug here.
Would Pastor Doug be in a mansion and I
would have a tent? I mean what is what
does it mean by according to our works?
Oh.
Well
you know I think that there are varying
degrees of reward and punishment
according to the Bible. First let's talk
about punishment.
Uh Jesus said he that knew his master's
will
and did not do it will be beaten with
many stripes because he knew what God
wanted. He that did not know and did not
do it will be beaten with few stripes.
Just notice
they're both going to be punished, but
differently. One many, one few. So
there's varying degrees of punishment.
Obviously
the duration and intensity of pain that
Adolf Hitler will experience in the lake
of fire would be more severe
than some lost you know 18-year-old that
committed suicide.
Um sadly though they may be lost
they're not going to experience the same
degree of punishment as Adolf Hitler.
Same thing with rewards. There are those
who have given more and sacrificed more
and loved the Lord uh and had you know
more good works and more self-denial
they may surprise everybody and the
people that we know nothing about could
be leading the parade in heaven.
And they'll have greater rewards.
Whether that means a bigger mansion, I
don't know. Uh some people a mansion
won't mean anything. But whatever the
rewards are they're going to be honored
somehow more in the kingdom.
You know you think of some people who
actually gave their life as a martyr.
You got Stephen for example.
And God rewards each person according to
their works and how faithful they were
in difficult situations.
for the Lord. Yeah. You know the verse
you're referring to about the punishment
of the wicked is Luke chapter 12 verse
48 that says he who knew the will of his
master and did not do it shall be beaten
with many stripes whereas the one who
didn't few stripes. So there's the verse
Luke 12:48.
Next caller that we have is Ivan
listening from Mexico. Ivan, welcome to
the program.
Uh how you good evening uh pastors. Um I
have a question for you guys in regards
to this verse.
I got the wrong verse. Oh, sorry. Um
I wanted to want I
I clarity on the where he where Jesus
where it says in the scriptures where
Jesus went down
to the heart of the earth and freed the
captives or something like that.
You're talking I think is it 1 Peter
chapter
uh 2 Pastor Ross where it says he
preached to the spirits in prison?
Yeah, that's it. That's it. Yeah. And I
think it might be let me see 1 Peter
chapter 2. I'm just I'm going from
memory now.
Uh no 1 Peter chapter 3
Three. uh verse 19. There it is. Yeah.
18:19. Yeah, for Christ also suffered
once for sins the just for the unjust
that he might bring us to God being put
to death in the flesh but made alive in
the spirit. Now the emphasis here is the
spirit. By whom through the spirit he
went and preached to the spirits in
prison. In other words spirits here is
small s. It's basically saying that it
was the same spirit the Holy Spirit that
rose Christ.
That spirit strove with people
who formerly were disobedient when once
the divine long-suffering waited in the
days of Noah.
God was long-suffering. That's when God
says and uh Peter is quoting from
Genesis chapter 6 verse 3 where he says
my spirit will not always strive with
man. His days will be 120 years. That's
pretty long-suffering to give a person
120 years.
So
Peter is just saying the same spirit
that strove with the lost people in
prison by the devil
imprisoned by sin.
The Bible says that you know people are
held captive by their sins.
That same spirit is the spirit that rose
Jesus. Jesus did not go from the cross
down to some cavern of hell and preach
to give lost people a second chance.
That would go against everything else
the Bible says where it tells us it's
appointed unto man once to die after
that the judgment. It's not die, second
chance, then judgment.
So uh this is an often misunderstood
verse.
All right, does that help Ivan?
Well yeah, I was just wondering who are
the captives that he freed?
Well he it's talking about
uh that when Noah preached in the days
before the flood God preached to those
that were in prison.
And the Lord
through the same spirit he strove with
them.
Some of the people during that 120 years
were saved before the flood. For one
thing Enoch was saved.
Uh Methuselah was saved. They all died
before the flood. Uh unfortunately as
far as the flood just Noah and his
family there were eight souls that were
saved. And uh Peter mentions that later
on also.
All right, well thanks for your call. Uh
we've got Carol listening in Oregon.
Carol, welcome to the program.
Good evening gentlemen. Thank you for
taking my call. Yeah. Um it's about the
new moon. I understand it was a
holiday or Sabbath or something observed
in the Old Testament, but I must confess
a degree of ignorance. Um I've seen it
mentioned
now and again
in the Bible in the same sentence along
with the weekly Sabbath like in Isaiah
where he says uh
one new moon to the next and one Sabbath
to the next all flesh will come to
worship. And I believe in the New
Testament too. I thought it was
Colossians. I think St. Paul also
mentioned the two in the same sentence
as though there were some link between
them, but I don't know enough about the
new moon to really tell. So I was hoping
you could fill in the picture.
Well yeah, well I'll do my best. Uh the
Jewish calendar was a lunar calendar. It
was governed by the months and the word
month we get from the word moon. They're
related.
And so they had the division of time.
There was the week which was of course
every Sabbath. A new week began. You had
the seventh day then you followed by the
first. The month they had a 27-day
calendar. It followed the lunar cycle.
The Jews would uh correct they correlate
the
um solar year with the lunar year by
adding a month. I think it was every 13
years they would add a month to
compensate. And so they actually had a
very accurate calendar.
Uh and when it says in heaven from one
new moon to another, from one Sabbath to
another, all flesh will come and worship
before me.
Now, I understand that he realized that
um
there are
four weeks
in a month, approximately. I think in
heaven that the months are going to have
28 days exactly. So, every fourth
Sabbath is going to be a new month, but
it's also Sabbath.
And so, it's the same from week to week
and month to month, all flesh will come
and worship before me.
But, the new moons were not part of the
original law or the 10 Commandments.
They were more connected with the
ceremonial services.
So, I know that's sort of a long
meandering answer, but uh appreciate
your openness, Carol. Hope that made
sense. And of course, the new moon could
fall on any day of the week, whereas the
seventh-day Sabbath was always on the
seventh day of the week. It didn't
change. Now, we have a book, I think,
that talks about feast days and
Sabbaths. We do, and we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks who
want to learn more about the Old
Testament feasts. The number to call is
800-835-6747,
and you can ask for the book New Moons
and Sabbaths, how much of those
ceremonial laws are binding today, if
any. Well, you'll be surprised at what
the Bible has to say. Yep. Next caller
that we have is Heather listening from
California. Heather, welcome to the
program. Thank you for taking my call.
Um
So, I have a question. It's um is it
ungodly and a sin to get surgery to
remove cancer? Why would you think it
might be? I mean, something generates
your question. Are you concerned it's a
lack of faith or something?
Um it was a a life or death thing for me
cuz I had a uterine cancer, and
some family members are telling me
saying like if I have the doctors remove
my uterus due to
uncontrolled bleeding, then I'm letting
Satan win.
No, I I sorry, I'd respectfully
disagree. I think that I know too many
people that have their lives saved and
lengthened by having um
you know,
a practical surgery. You know, you don't
want to go to any quack, but if if you
are if you're following the best medical
practices and you combine
faith
with good living practices, take care of
your health.
But, if there's a medical procedure and
it's going to help remove cancer,
by all means.
I mean, even in the Bible when Hezekiah
was healed, God told Isaiah to have him
place a poultice of figs on this boil.
So, he used some medical procedure.
And the Bible tells us in Ezekiel, the
leaves of the tree are for medicine.
So, using some medical procedure, Luke,
the one who wrote the book of Acts, the
Gospel of Luke, was a physician.
There's no Bible mandate that we should
not use doctors and surgery or medical
procedures. And you know, God has given
certain gifts to certain individuals
where they have a keen mind, they're
able to discern uh what symptoms might
be. They're able to address the disease.
Now, ultimately, we recognize that all
healing really comes from God, but God
can choose to use doctors and nurses and
medicine uh and surgery. And uh we want
to have faith, but also utilize the
resources he provided. I thank God for
good doctors. Absolutely.
Thank you for your call. We've got uh
let's see, Aaron listening from um or
Aaron, rather. Aaron listening from New
York. Aaron, welcome to the program.
Good evening, pastors. Yeah. In the
first part of Luke chapter 18, Jesus
told the parable of the persistent
widow, teaching his followers to keep
praying for something and not to give
up.
Yes.
But, in Matthew chapter 6, verse 7,
Jesus said to his followers,
"Do not use vain repetitions as the
heathen do, for they think that they
will be heard for their many words."
Mhm. My question is, how can we pray
persistently persistently without using
vain repetitions?
Yeah, good question. It's a good
question, and I I needed that answered
myself when I first read those verses.
Jesus, when he says, "Do not pray in
vain repetition as the heathen do."
Um you know, there are a lot of heathen
religions that will uh they'll count a
bead and say every time they say a bead,
they repeat a prayer. They'll just keep
saying the same thing over and over
again as though God is deaf.
Now, when Elijah prayed for rain, he
prayed seven times in one day, "Lord,
send the rain." His prayer may have
sounded a little different each time,
but he kept praying for rain. If you're
praying for a loved one or you're
praying about a separate issue, there's
nothing wrong with repeating that
prayer. Paul says that he prayed three
times about a medical problem that he
had,
and then God finally said, "No, Paul,
stop praying about that because the
answer's no."
So, you know, but uh if you're praying
for something good,
um the children of Israel, they prayed
for deliverance from their enemies for
years
sometimes. So, nothing wrong with
praying persistently for a good thing.
You just don't want to sit there and go,
"Lord, feed me now. Lord, feed me now.
Lord, feed me now." And I've heard
heathen prayers that sound like that. I
would respectfully disagree
with the priests that tell people that
if you want to be forgiven, you must
repeat the Hail Mary or the Our Father
15 times in a row. That's praying in
vain repetition.
But, to say I'm going to continue to
pray for the salvation of a loved one
uh for years, that's a different issue.
There's examples of that in the Bible.
Okay. Next caller that we have is Robert
listening in New Jersey. Robert, welcome
to the program.
Uh good evening, pastors uh Doug and
pastor uh John.
Evening. My question is um
concerning a small little
I found a little curious in the in the
Bible. The The Bible states that
God is not a god of confusion.
Yet, in two instances,
he seems to have caused it. Like, for
example,
on in Genesis 11:7,
he caused confusion around the Tower of
Babel
to to to to disrupt the languages and
then have the people scattered
throughout the earth.
And another um instance was
the Ammonites who were who attacked
small force of Israel.
It says
in the history of Israel
Ammonites were among
the army allied against King
Jehoshaphat, and God caused confusion
among them. Yes. And they destroyed
themselves. And that's 2 Chronicles
20:1-23.
Yep. So, how do I
How do we um
How do you reconcile the two?
What What do we make of this? Yeah, God
is not the author of confusion. I think
that's 1 Corinthians 14.
Uh he says, "Let all things that be done
decently." God, of course, is talking
about his people.
And God was extremely
um
precise
in telling the children of Israel to be
fastidious, clean, orderly in what they
did in the camp, in the services.
Um and Paul repeats that in the church,
that we should be orderly. Order is a
blessing of God. Disorder and chaos is a
curse that he often sent to the enemies.
Because the people of Babylon were
rebelling against God,
he sent them chaos and confusion. Many
times in the Bible,
God will confound is one of the words
that's used, the enemies,
and confuse and frustrate their plans.
He did it to the Amalekites and probably
several others. I think at one point uh
during the battle of Gideon, they all
turned on each other in the chaos.
And so, you'll see that um
order
and um
uh organization are a blessing
that God wants among his people. He
wants us to strive for that. When we
reject God and we embrace the devil,
then you're going to have disorder and
chaos. You know, the verse you're
referring to that you mentioned a
pastor, 1 Corinthians chapter 14,
there's two parts to the verse. It says,
"For God is not the author of confusion,
but of peace." The next part of the
verse says, "As in all of the churches
of the saints." Mhm. So, specifically,
uh Paul is speaking about when it comes
to worship, when it comes to activities
within the church, there needs to be
order. Uh things need to be done
decently.
Uh you don't want to have confusion in
the church, especially when it comes to
worship. That's quite different than
when God brought a judgment upon the
Tower of Babel or upon the enemies of
God's people.
Okay, good question. Thank you. We've
got let's see, Dave is listening from uh
Alaska. Dave, welcome to the program.
Thank you, gentlemen. I appreciate your
time. I'm going to try and make this
quick and concise.
Basically, I've got a history of mental
illness, and I feel like I've always had
this impression of that someone wants me
to be a missionary in order to be saved,
but I can't live without my meds.
Is Satan capable of impersonating God in
order to tell them to do something to
their own destruction?
Okay, good question.
Uh is Satan able to uh impersonate God?
Well, yes and no. In other words, Satan
can never be God. Does he try to deceive
people into thinking that um
God is speaking to them? Oh, yeah.
There's a lot of religions in the world
that are false, and they're sure God is
guiding them.
And so, Satan is impersonating God, and
he's deceiving.
Um so, how do we know whether it's God
or, you know, the devil impersonating
God? For one thing, we follow his word.
Uh we listen to Christian counsel.
We uh
obey the promptings of his spirit as in
harmony with his word. Look for
providential openings. In fact, I you
might be blessed, um
by a book I wrote, Dave, and it's called
uh How to Know the Will of God.
So, uh one of the things that book will
do is it'll try and give you some tools
so you can know is this an impression
from the Lord? Is God guiding me to be a
missionary, as you say, or whatever? Or
is this is the devil messing with my
head thinking I can't be saved unless
I'm a missionary?
First of all, I don't think God calls
everybody to be missionaries. Uh there
are different gifts that are given to
different people.
I think that you look in 1 Corinthians
chapter 12 and chapter 14, talks about
different gifts of the spirit.
Not everyone's a pastor or a teacher.
If you'd like to receive the book, I
think it's called Determining the Will
of God, and we'll be happy to send it to
you, Dave, or anyone who calls and asks.
The number is 800-835-6747.
And again, the book is called
Determining the Will of God, and we'll
be happy to get it in the mail and send
it to you. We've got Eric listening in
New Jersey. Eric, welcome to the
program.
Hi, Douglas. I
congratulate you guys.
Uh I have a question in Matthew chapter
4 verse 5.
Mhm.
Uh say that
I hope you understand me, that the the
end the devil took him
up into the holy city.
Took him him on the pinnacle of the
temple. Yes.
My question is how
how how the devil the devil took Jesus
because Jesus was a man? Yes.
Well, that that tells us something about
the the power of the devil. Now, whether
the devil
physically put him there, I mean, I I'm
inclined to think he did because he he
wanted him to jump and physically die.
And but that tells you something about
the devil to actually transport
three-dimensional objects or people or
creatures.
Um
so it says he took him up to the temple.
It probably wasn't just a vision of the
temple.
And said, "Throw yourself down."
Um by the way, I was reading this week
that uh the I think is it Josephus tells
us, I believe, that James, the brother
of Jesus, so angered the scribes, they
ultimately took him to the top of the
temple and threw him off. Same place
where the devil took Jesus, the brother
of James the brother of Jesus, half
brother,
was tossed off the temple.
So,
I think uh yeah, the devil took him up
there. What what do you think? Yeah.
Absolutely. And of course, the devil
does have power to move things. I mean,
you There there are those who are
involved in a different seance or cults,
and they'll testify that things do move.
Tables move, people move, so the devil
does have power to move things. Yeah.
And move people. It happens on Star
Trek, it must be true.
Must be true, huh?
Yeah. All right. Sorry, folks. Forgive
me for that. Thank you. Thank you, Eric,
for your call. Uh we've got Brian
listening in Washington. Brian, welcome
to the program.
Hi, Douglas. Hi, Ross. Hi. Um I've got a
question on Genesis 32:22
through 32. Yeah.
Um can you explain the purpose of
Jacob's wrestling with God
and why his hip was permanently
displaced?
Okay.
Yeah, I'll I'll do my best. Of course,
Jacob had deceived his his uh parents
and his brother.
And through um deceiving, he tried to
steal his birthright. Uh now he's coming
back into the promised land. And um
he's wanting to know that God forgave
him. I think Jacob wrestling with the
angel, of course, you can't wrestle with
God. God can pin you in a fraction of a
second. Uh God can toss you out of the
ring. So, how do you wrestle with God?
That is I think God allowed that to show
that sometimes we wrestle with God in
prayer. Jacob went off by himself to
pray.
And then the man appears, and he thought
that it would maybe there was some
vandal or robber, and Jacob
instinctively, you know, tries to go to
defend himself.
And one hold after another doesn't seem
to work. And they they wrestle for quite
a while.
And um
I think it's there to depict prayer. And
it actually talks about the time of
Jacob's trouble in the prophecies, and I
forget is it uh
Jeremiah? Says it's the time of Jacob's
trouble. And it depicts this wrestling.
So, finally, Jacob uh the angel touches
him, and it puts his hip out of joint.
He really had to be humbled, but he
would not let even though he's in
intense pain, he would not let go of
God, and he said, "I will not let you go
unless you bless me." This is where
Jacob gets his name changed to Israel,
one who triumphs as a prince with God.
And when we hang on to God's promises,
we triumph, we get a new name. This is a
whole scenario in that in the context of
wrestling in prayer. I think the verse
you're referring to there, Pastor Doug,
Jeremiah chapter 30 verse 7, talks about
Jacob's wrestling, Jacob's time of
trouble. And of course, that's the type
of God's people in the last days, their
faith will be tried. And they will have
to claim those promises and hold on to
them. In essence, they go through a
Jacob time of trouble.
That's true.
Now, listening friends, we are going to
be wrapping up. We sort of do this in
two stages. For our friends listening on
satellite radio, we're going to say,
"God bless until next week." The rest of
you, stay tuned. We're going to be doing
some rapid-fire internet questions that
have come in in just a moment.
Thank you for listening to today's
broadcast. We hope you understand your
Bible even better than before. Bible
Answers Live is produced by Amazing
Facts International, a faith-based
ministry located in Granite Bay,
California.
Hello, friends. Welcome back to Bible
Answers Live, and we're going to be
taking some of your email and internet
questions that have come in. And if you
have a Bible question that you'd like to
email to us, the email address is
balquestions@amazingfacts.org.
All right, Pastor Doug, we have Charlene
from England, and she'd like to know,
"Where did Cain find his wife?"
Yeah, that's a common question because
people begin reading the Bible, and then
after Cain kills his brother, and he's
sort of evicted to the land of Nod, God
places a mark on Cain, says Cain took
his wife.
And you go, "Whoa, whoa, wait a second
here. There was Cain and Abel, he kills
his brother, there's only Adam and Eve.
Where's the wife come from?"
Well, when you get to Genesis chapter 5,
we realize that it only mentions the
firstborn boys typically in this
patriarchal society.
It says Adam and Eve had other sons and
daughters.
And so,
uh Cain and Seth, and the other
patriarchs, they often married their
sisters. They had to marry their
sisters.
If you think about it,
Adam sort of married his sister. I mean,
they both
were created by the same parent, you
might say. And you go further down in
the Bible, uh Abraham married his half
sister.
Uh Jacob married his first cousin. It
was not There was no genetic problems
when they married their sisters back in
the beginning cuz people's genes were
perfectly
uh robust.
Okay, another question that we have.
Linda's asking, "Did Jesus take the
Nazarite vow?"
Yeah, good question. It doesn't
specifically say it, but it is possible
that Jesus took the Nazarite vow or that
Mary and Joseph had Jesus follow that
vow up until his baptism. A person might
take the vow for a limited period of
time.
Or a person might take the vow until,
you know, a certain age. And certainly
when Christ was baptized, it says then
he was, you know, drinking grape juice,
which a Nazarite was not supposed to do.
That's why so many artists depict Jesus
with the longer hair
cuz the Nazarites were not supposed to
cut their hair like Samson.
Um Samuel had taken the Nazarite vow.
And but he probably took it for life.
So, we don't know, but it is possible he
took it up until his baptism.
Okay, we have another question. How do
we uh know if we have true faith without
being presumptuous?
Yeah, how do you know if
the Bible says you don't want to tempt
the Lord. You don't say, "Lord, I've got
faith that I can jump off the temple."
Uh cuz that is tempting the Lord.
But um if there's something in God's
word where he's giving us some
direction,
we can follow that with confidence. And
other examples in the Bible, we know
we're safe.
That uses up all our question times for
this program, friends. God willing,
we'll be studying his word together with
you again next week.
Bible Answers Live, honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions.